the economy bounces back in a major way
in the third quarter
democrats get triumphaless before the
votes are in and news breaks on hunter
biden that could be some trouble for joe
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
this show is sponsored by expressvpn
stop putting your online data at risk
get protected at expressvpn.com
ben this is the final friday before the
election the final friday
the final countdown okay
so we're gonna get to everything news
related in just one second first
let us talk about the fact that there is
nothing worse than having malware on
your computer if you've ever had this
if somebody has ever put ransomware on
your computer where they lock all of
your files and then basically they
blackmail you into paying them
so they can unlock your files well then
you know ransomware
malware all this stuff sucks what you
need is something that will protect you
and this is where pcmatic comes in
pcmatic is a next-generation anti-virus
designed to stop modern threats like
ransomware
independent testing from a v test just
named pcmatic as a top performer in the
cyber security industry
giving it the best performance award for
2019. only pcmatic has american research
development and support
pcmatic's competition is foreign made
often in countries where malware
originates
pcmatic will block annoying and
malicious ads for hassle-free web
browsing it makes your computer faster
and more reliable even after years of
use
pcmatic protects windows computers
including xp vista windows 7 8 and 10
windows servers max macbooks and android
phones and tablets and
it's just 50 bucks for five devices for
one year with a full 30 day money back
guarantee if you act right now pcmatic
has offered my listeners a free month of
security protection with the purchase of
an annual license if you're not
protecting yourself from malware
you're making a big mistake because
you're only going to recognize what a
big mistake that is
the moment that malware hits your
computer to access this offer and
protect yourself go to pcmatic.com
ben again get that world-class security
that keeps your computer running great
go to pcmatic.com
ben okay so going into the final weekend
of the election
the big piece of news really should be
the fact that the economy bounced back
in a massive way
in the third quarter there was a massive
q3 recovery number
gdp rose at 33.1 percent for the quarter
on an annualized basis
that is a remarkable turnaround from the
plunge of 31.4 percent the economy
registered in the second quarter
but economists immediately started
downplaying this thing because people
shouldn't believe that maybe having
trump in charge is good
so instead we're going to pretend that
things remain awful
even though the reality is that that's a
pretty damned good recovery considering
that half the country is still shut down
new york new jersey
california all these places are still
shut down guy just came from california
it is still shut down over there
and it's going to be renewed in its
shutdown that is a testament to the
underlying strength of the economy that
it bounced back in such a strong way
with one arm tied
behind its back john burkett saint
laurent senior portfolio manager
essential wealth advisor says the
obvious caveat is when you drop 30
and you gain 30 you're still below where
you started that's because if you drop
30 from 100 you're now at 70 percent
okay and then if you take 30 of 70 30 of
70 is not 30.
right so you're back up and it's like 90
92. so you're still below where you
started
but the bottom line is that that is
indeed a massive massive recovery
from what was an exogenous shock to the
system
that could not have been foreseen or
predicted if it could have been then
presumably somebody in europe would have
predicted it
i'm constantly amazed at the willingness
of everybody in the united states to
believe that president trump knew what
was going on decided deliberately to
allow this thing
to happen and wreck the american economy
in not only a re-election year but just
as a general moral matter he was like oh
you know what i'm gonna let two hundred
thousand people die for no reason at all
and lose my reelection bid on
on that basis it makes perfect sense
it's the same illogical stupidity
and moral blindness that led the left to
declare that bush lied people died in
iraq that bush deliberately took us to
war in iraq knowing there were no
weapons of mass destruction
because he was just that evil it was war
for oil it was war for revenge and all
that kind of crap
and the realities lots of mistakes get
made in politics because lots of
mistakes get made
in life but one of the things that is
perfectly obvious that the business
community
correctly trusts the trump
administration to not
destroy business on the basis of other
priorities
and that is why businesses have been
rehiring it's why businesses have been
coming back
vice president pence spoke about this
yesterday bragged about the economy
growing more than 33
this should be the talking point going
into the weekend is that joe biden is
likely
to stagnate the economy at an
extraordinary level
he's already talked about radically
raising taxes he's talked about raising
the corporate income tax rate
he's talked about raising the top income
tax rate he's talked about raising the
the
payroll tax he has talked about
extraordinary regulations
particularly regulations that benefit
big labor everything that he has talked
about is likely to dampen the economy
trump is more trusted than than biden is
on the economy and he should be
here is mike pence making the case
yesterday
with today's new gdp numbers just this
morning
the american economy grew by more than
33 percent
in the third quarter shattering any
previous american record the great
american comeback is on
okay so that should be the final pitch
going into the election as we will see
that is not the final pitch going into
the election instead it's a bunch of
other sort of random things that people
don't care about nearly as much which is
not a great election strategy
however the economists are already
starting to try to play this down so
nbc news says the strong gdp figure
camouflages the k-shaped nature of the
recovery that has caused economic
sectors such as housing to rebound
strongly while other industries like
airlines and restaurants remain morbid
okay but exactly how are you supposed to
fix that i mean we're in the middle of
covid still
so yes a lot of restaurants are shot
because if they are indoor restaurants
with
a lot of recirculated air conditioning
people are afraid that they are going to
get covered
and it turns out that airlines have been
hit really hard even though the studies
tend to show that there's not
transmission on airlines
uh there have been no serious outbreaks
on any airline even though we are now up
over a million passengers a day
in the united states which is not nearly
where it was but i've traveled in the
recent past the planes are fairly full
and there's been no outbreak on planes
because planes do have these hepa
filters that
have filtered the air and when they
recycle the air they're actually taking
out the virus when they recycle the air
basically somebody would have to sneeze
directly on you in close quarters
or you know leave their germs in the
bathroom or something in order for you
to get it on a plane everybody on these
planes is masked up anyway
and they do have the power under the law
to kick you off a plane if you refuse to
mask properly on a plane so there's not
been any outbreaks
on planes but the goal of the media is
to downplay the recovery because again
what the recovery shows is that
the measures that trump has been taking
are actually
successful not just because he wants to
reopen but also because
president trump would would like to
retain
a lot of the economic base that made the
economy so strong leading up to the
covid depression
remember before covert depression the
economy was going great guns i mean we
had the lowest unemployment rate in half
a century
wages were rising extraordinarily high
they were rising mostly at the bottom
end of the spectrum
the median income in the united states
had risen dramatically under president
trump
under the first three years of his
administration so the underlying
fundamentals remain good
and this should be the argument right
the argument going into the election
should be the underlying fundamentals of
the economy under trump
would be much much much stronger than
the underlying fundamentals of an
economy under joe biden who would seek
to put restraints on the economy
in the name of various other priorities
ranging from a green new deal
to late to big labor's priorities to the
attempt to create income equality which
of course is an idiotic goal income
equality should not be the goal
prosperity should be the goal
anybody who focuses on income equality
as opposed to prosperity for everybody
is missing the boat you can have income
equality in absolute poverty and you can
have income inequality
and absolute wealth right there's a lot
of income inequality between me and bill
gates
thank god i do really well the income
inequality means nothing
what matters is the absolute level of
income and what kind of life people are
able to lead prosperity
is the important measure not income
inequality
okay but here's the thing joe biden
would like to actually
harm the economy his his actual policy
goals are likely to harm the economy
apparently he's flirting with elizabeth
warren politico citing three democratic
officials who have spoken with warren's
inner circle
reports that the massachusetts senator
and third place
third place democratic presidential
candidate has her eyes set on the role
of treasury secretary
and plans to advocate for herself
starting next week should democrats take
control of the white house she wants it
to the officials told the news agency of
warren's ambitions as politico notes the
treasury secretary in the next
president's
administration will be tasked with
steering the us economy out of deep
recession
even as the country struggles to
struggle with the coronavirus
pandemic this means presumably that
elizabeth warren will be negotiating
budgets
it means that elizabeth warren will be
trying to cram down particular programs
on business
via the fed her plan her economic plan
was likely to
really really have a dire impact on the
economy i mean she was calling for a
full-on wealth tax
right she wanted wide scale wealth
confiscation for people with a net worth
greater than 50 million dollars and as i
pointed out at the time
measuring people by their net worth is
not actually a measure of their wealth
a net worth is what your stock is worth
let's say you're on a private company
let's say that your private company is
worth
200 million dollars okay which means
let's say it's a five times ebitda
calculation that means that the company
actually has 40 million dollars in
business every year
but your expenses are 38 million or 39
million right so you do 40 million
40 million and gross every year five
times ebitda means that you end up at a
200 million
valuation let's say that you own 50 of
that company
well you are worth quote unquote 100
million dollars the problem is
you can't actually liquidate your asset
in the company for a hundred million
dollars not actually worth that
so if you're talking about a two percent
tax on a hundred million dollars
a two percent wealth tax on a hundred
million dollars then what you would
actually be talking about
is a two million dollar tax every single
year
for a company that may not actually be
earning two million dollars in profit
okay so none of this makes any sense but
elizabeth warren's plans didn't have to
make sense they were just confiscatory
that was all it was about
the goal of course would be to quash
people
who are the actual investors in the
economy i know that we love to believe
that what actually drives the economy is
low level spending that is not what
drives the economy what drives the
economy is people creating new
excellent products and services with
heavy levels of investment that actually
change your life this is the famous
henry ford line
that if i had done what the market
wanted i would have created a more
efficient horse and buggy
right it is it is entrepreneurs and
innovators and people who are constantly
attempting
to discern what the public would love to
see from their imagination
and then investing their own resources
time and money in that stuff that is
what drives the economy forward that is
why you are living a better lifestyle
now than you would have in 1980 for all
of the
bizarre nostalgia for living standards
in 1950
if you lived in 1950 okay if you're the
richest person in 1950
you had less amenities available to you
than the poorest person who's living in
the united states today right there were
no cell phones in 1950
you were lucky if you had a nice car in
if you had a house that was like a big
deal in 1950 the average
average living space in the united
states is significantly larger than the
average living space was
in 1950 there's this nostalgia for a
time that didn't exist
and it's funny people on the left accuse
the right of having nostalgia for a time
that didn't exist in the 1950s this sort
of clean
socially conservative time okay but the
reality is
that everybody on the left has a
nostalgia for an economy that didn't
exist in the 1950s
okay they have a nostalgia for a time
they would not like no one had air
conditioning in the 1950s everybody has
their conditioning now that is because
of
entrepreneurialism and innovation and
it's all that stuff that democrats would
like to see
go by the wayside so the final pitch
for trump should in fact be the economy
that should be the final pitch
if you elect democrats the economy will
tank and he's made that case
and he has said that the problem is it's
been overshadowed by him making the case
on a variety of other topics it should
have been a singular message
the economy was great until coveted the
economy will only be great again after
covet if you allow business to do what
business does
and you cannot do that if you're talking
about endless lockdowns you cannot do
that if you are talking about
outsourcing america's policy to people
who do not do multivariate analysis
of all of the covid based issues right
if you're just outsourcing everything to
dr fauci
and dr fauci's sole goal in life is not
to balance the economic needs of the
american people
with the need to protect elderly from
covid right his sole goal i mean he's
the head of the nia id right i mean he's
the head of the national institute for
allergies and infectious diseases he's
not the head
of the fed that means he does a single
variable analysis
what activity is most likely to preserve
the lives of people who are above the
age of 70.
but you do have to balance all these
things when you make public policy right
how do you balance the risk to people
above the age of 70 with the risk
to an economy that supports 330 million
people
how do you balance the risk of of
additional life lost at age 85
with the risk of not allowing children
to go to school right single variable
analysis is not sufficient in politics
this is why it was really funny jared
kushner was getting batted around
yesterday by the media
because he says that trump took back
covered making policy from the doctors
and be like oh he shouldn't take back
that policy well i didn't elect fauci i
mean
i i'm more than willing to hear fauci's
perspective he knows more about
allergies and infectious diseases than i
do i'm also willing to hear the
perspective
of j batacharia from stanford university
because he's an actual epidemiologist
right
i'm willing to listen to that as well
but we elect policy makers we don't
elect doctors
if you want to elect a doctor you're
free to go to a doctor anytime you
choose
that should be trump's closing pitch it
is a little bit
it's probably not enough right now okay
in just a second we will get to the
the actual pitch the democrats are
making okay so the pitch republicans
should be making is look at this
economic recovery if you'd like to see
it continue
you need to elect republicans democrats
are making a counter pitch and that is
that republicans are deeply immoral and
you should never be friends with them
that really is their final pitch and
that's why that pitch
beyond the election is going to have
dire ramifications for all the talk from
joe biden about
no red state america no blue state
america i'm going to be president
for all americans all americans come on
man
well let's be real about this he is not
he's not and he has no intention of
being
joe biden is a corrupt democratic
politician he will move whichever way
the wind blows the winds in his party
are moving very strongly in favor of the
sort of
don't ever talk with a republican again
mentality that you see
in today's canceled culture that
canceled culture means an awful lot
because when you talk about politics
affecting your everyday life there are
two ways politics can affect your
everyday life one
is the actual government policy
affecting your everyday life tax rates
go up
regulations go up the other way is the
way we all know politics affects our
everyday life
which is the social ostracization the
left has now thrust upon anybody who
thinks differently
if you think differently if you're the
girl scouts they will ostracize you
right if you if you tweet out a nice
thing about amy coney barrett
they will force you to back down if you
are a person working in an office
and you suggest just suggest that barack
obama is a bad president
you will be labeled a racist if you say
that you support trump
you will obviously be labeled the racist
that is how politics affects your
everyday life and democrats have
invested heavily
in that message because it is a social
intimidation campaign to get you to cave
and vote democrat
that is what is happening on the left
side of the outlet is an overt and
covert campaign
we'll get to that in just one moment
first this holiday season more people
will be mailing stuff than ever before i
mean
in many states you literally cannot go
away for the holidays
my sister wanted to come down to florida
for thanksgiving
she can't because if she goes back to
where she is from then they're going to
quarantine her for two weeks so that
means that we're gonna be mailing each
other lots of gifts right i mean we're
gonna be using the mail a lot but one
thing you don't want to do is slap over
all of those past
packages to the post office instead what
you'd really like to do
is do this in quick and convenient
fashion and at less cost how do you do
that stamps.com anything you do at the
post office you can do with just a few
clicks plus
stamps.com saves you money with deep
discounts you can't even get at the post
office
here at the daily wire we've used
stamps.com since 2017.
no more wasting our time stamps.com
brings the services of the us postal
service and ups directly
to your computer stamps.com is a
must-have for any business
whether you are a small office sending
out invoices in an online seller
fulfilling orders during this
record-setting
holiday display season or even a giant
warehouse sending thousands of packages
a day
stamps.com can handle all of it with
ease simply use your computer to print
official us postage 24 7
for any letter any package any class of
mail anywhere you want to send it
once your mail is ready just schedule a
pick up or drop it off it is that simple
with stamps.com you get five cents off
every first class stamp and up to 40
off priority mail up to 62 off ups
shipping rates
stamps.com is a no-brainer it takes you
time it saves you money it's no wonder
over 900 000 small businesses already
use stamps.com right now there is no
risk with my promo code shapiro you get
a special offer that includes a
four-week trial
plus free postage and a digital scale no
long-term commitment no contracts just
go to stamps.com click on that
microphone at the top of the homepage
type in shapirostamps.com never go to
the post office again remember
stamps.com enter
promo code shapiro and then you never
have to go to the post office again and
you get that very special deal
okay so the closing pitch for democrats
is the same as the pitch has always been
you're a bad person if you vote
republican right has nothing to do with
republican policies
it has nothing to do with why joe biden
will be better for the country
it has to do with you you on a personal
level you
yeah you bob you're a bad person if you
vote for donald trump
hey don lemon is making this case
overtly in the media you must be
delusional vote for
donald trump says don lemon over tienen
in fact he says i'm getting rid of trump
voters in my life
there are people who i like who are
trump voters i can't have them in my
life because they're so delusional here
is don lemon on cnn
saying the quiet part out loud about
what the democratic agenda really is
which is to close the overton window to
the point where you no longer are
allowed in polite society
if you have conversations that differ
from the mainstream
i have many people who i love in my life
and yeah i come from a red state i've
lived in
several red states there are a lot of
friends who i had to really get rid of
because they they are so nonsensical
when it comes to this issue they have
the whole every single talking point
that they hear on state tv
and that they hear from this president
they repeat it and they are blinded by
it
i just i had to get rid of a lot of
people in my life because sometimes you
just have to let them go i think that
they have to
hit rock bottom like an addict right and
they have to want to get help
they have to want to know the truth they
have to want to live in reality they
have to want to be responsible
so a long time ago alexis de tocqueville
who's still the greatest observer of
america in american life
he wrote back in the 1840s and he was
writing about touring the united states
of america
and alexis de tocqueville talked about
the
big problem in american life he said one
of the big problems is that
social sanctions when used can be
extraordinarily powerful
he says that the mob could allow freedom
of thought technically
but only to an extent right here's the
tocqueville again writing nearly two
centuries ago
the person who says they are for freedom
of thought but in favor of social
stricture of mainstream opinion
he says quote you are free to think
differently from me and to retain your
life your property and all that you
possess
but if such be your determination you're
henceforth an alien among your people
you may retain your civil rights but
they will be useless to you for you will
be never chosen by your fellow citizens
if you solicit their suffrages
and they will effect to scorn you if you
solicit their esteem you will remain
among men but you will be deprived of
the rights of mankind
your fellow creatures will shun you like
an impure being and those who are most
persuaded of your innocence will abandon
you too
unless they should be shunned in their
turn go in peace i have given you your
life but it is ex
it is in existence incomparably worse
than death
the majority lives in the perpetual
practice of self-applause and there are
certain truths which the americans can
only learn from strangers
or from experience right so the idea
here is again that social structure
is one way that politics is done the
left knows this the left knows this
and so they've decided that they are
going to excoriate anybody who votes
differently
than they do and you see this in nearly
every arena of american life
it's why it feels like the country is
falling apart it used to be that you
would get together with somebody and you
go to a baseball game
and at the baseball game you put your
politics aside because there was a
baseline recognition
that you were both americans and that
while you may have different political
priorities in terms of how you vote
you still want what's best for america
you still believe in traditional
american values
that has gone by the wayside people on
the left refuse to acknowledge this
people on the right they literally
refuse to acknowledge it if you vote for
donald trump it is because you are a
racist
it is not in spite of the you're not
voting trump to stop the predations of
the left you're voting trump because you
buy into the worst excesses
of donald trump the reason it's because
you love it you love it you're a bad
person if you vote a particular way
right this is why jonathan chait
supposedly open-minded liberal
he calls charlie cook editor-in-chief of
national view and me he says we are
we are racist because charlie is
considering voting for trump and because
i've said i will vote for trump
and this is how they feel about you
right this is why maisie hirono
yesterday suggested that 40 of americans
are awful people
amazing hirono again she's the dumb
dumbest member of the democratic party
but in her stupidity she speaks truth
yesterday
here is what she had to say about 40 of
the american people this is the final
democratic pitch because the idea is do
you want to be part of that 40
of people no i didn't think so didn't
think so right here's maizie hirono
yesterday saying 40
of the country 40 four in 10 americans
are angry resentful and fearful
this is the actual closing pitch put
aside all the policy stuff put aside the
donald trump is bad stuff the reason
they hate trump is not because they hate
trump so much it's because they hate
everybody who would possibly vote for
trump or think of voting for trump and
trump is just the
brutal and vulgar version of those
people you can't have 40
or so of the country being so angry
that they would continue to vote for
somebody like trump who will do
absolutely nothing to improve their
lives
right but he speaks to their anger
resentments
and fear of people like you and me
alrighty so leading up to the election
then democrats are
pretty confident that they are going to
be able to ram through
their agenda they're pretty sure that
joe biden is going to be elected now
according to the polling they are
probably right now there is a plausible
read of the polling or the polls don't
actually have to be wrong in trump wins
okay in order for that to happen trump
simply has to
close the gap in a couple of states
right yes he has to close the gap in
pennsylvania most importantly
but he needs to win georgia win north
carolina win
arizona and win florida right now all of
those are margin of error states
pennsylvania is slightly outside of
margin of error but not by much
minnesota is also very close so there's
a way
for trump to win it's not implausible it
it
bottom line here is that it could go one
of several different ways
there's not really a way that it's a
blowout for trump and there's just not i
mean he's down seven points in the
national polling there is literally no
way he's gonna win the popular vote
okay that is the one safe prediction i
can make donald trump's not gonna win
the popular vote people in california
are standing in line to vote against
trump even though it makes
absolutely no difference to the
presidential outcome because california
will remain blue
okay but there is a world where trump
wins a fairly broad electoral college
victory
where he wins florida georgia north
carolina arizona let's say minnesota and
pennsylvania
right that means that he wins a as broad
an electoral victory as he did last time
there's a plausible road where joe biden
wins going away
where biden swings all those states
where biden wins florida he wins georgia
he wins north carolina he wins iowa
he wins wisconsin he wins ohio because
ohio is tied
the polls would not have to be wrong for
any of this to happen by the way
right right now texas is within margin
of error so biden could theoretically
win texas and the polls couldn't be
wrong so
recognize that there is a lot of
flexibility in those polling numbers
when people say
the polls were wrong no there's actually
there's a range
in which polls are still considered
accurate if you're within like two or
three points
of the final outcome those polls are
still basically considered accurate this
is why you have
margin of error measurements on polls so
nobody should be too sanguine about
where we are in this election
nor should people on the right think
that if donald trump loses that that is
solely because of voter fraud i have
trump voters who come up to me sometimes
and they say this sort of stuff right i
voted for trump already by the way
in florida i already voted early like a
lot of people okay
yesterday i was i was walking around and
a fellow pulled me over
uh and he and he said you know if trump
loses it seems to me the only way trump
can lose if there's massive voter fraud
and i said
there's always the possibility of voter
fraud but i don't think that that's the
only way the trump could lose and i
think that we should get out of this
mindset
well the problem is that the left is in
that mindset right everybody seems to be
in that mindset a lot of trump voters
think that if trump loses it's going to
be because the system is corrupt
i mean that's true for the media okay
the media had a massive outsized
influence on this election
they are corrupt but it's not because
the voting system is corrupt the left is
saying the same thing if trump wins
it's got to be because of voter fraud
and this leads nancy pelosi
to say literally as we'll see that no
matter how the voting goes on tuesday if
you just keep counting the votes long
enough
joe biden will be president of the
united states here is the speaker of the
house
i feel very confident that joe biden
will be elected president
on tuesday whatever the
end count is but on the election that
occurs on tuesday he will be elected on
january 20th he will
be inaugurated president of the united
states he just keep counting the votes
long enough
and uh and joe biden will be elected
president of the united states this is
why democrats keep suggesting that
republicans are trying voter suppression
there's no voter suppression guys okay
we're gonna have more votes in this
election than any election in history
bar none we've had 70 million early
votes at this point 70 million
there were only about 135 million votes
in the last election
okay so we have already surpassed half
of the vote total and we haven't had
election day yet
so you know this talk about voter fraud
or voter suppression
is wildly overblown and the fact that
nancy pelosi keeps talking about so
funny folks on the left
the folks at the social media companies
they'll say how could trump talk about
voter fraud that's so bad
i don't understand why talking about
voter suppression is significantly
better than talking about voter fraud
there is no widespread voter suppression
and there is no widespread voter fraud
because put all that aside because i
don't think it's real i don't think
there's
i don't think hundreds of thousands of
people are mailing in fake ballots i
think we have measures to take if that
is the case
voter fraud matters on the small scale
it does not tend to matter on a broad
national scale where again the margin of
victory is gonna be hundreds of
thousands of votes
at the very least tens of thousands of
votes we'll get some more of this in
just one second first
let's talk about the fact that halloween
is coming up policy genius would like to
mark the occasion by making something
less scary
life insurance shopping for life
insurance can seem like a daunting task
a policy genius makes it easy they
combine a cutting edge insurance
marketplace with help
from licensed experts to save you time
and save you money right now you could
say 50
or more by using policy genius to
compare life insurance when you're
shopping for a policy that could last
for more than a decade the savings
really do start to add up here's how it
works first
head on over to policygenius.com in
minutes you can work out how much
coverage you need
and you can compare quotes from top
insurers to find your best price policy
genius will compare policies
starting at as little as one dollar a
day you might even be eligible to skip
that in-person medical exam
once you apply the policy genius team
will handle all the paperwork and the
red tape
here's the best part they work for you
not the insurance company so if you hit
any speed bumps during the application
process
they'll take care of everything for you
that kind of service has earned policy
genius a five-star rating across over 1
600 reviews
on trustpilot and google so if you need
life insurance
really you have but one choice the long
dock of moria or head over to
policygenius.com right now
to get started you could say 50 or more
by comparing quotes policy genius when
it comes to insurance it is nice and
extremely important to get it right be a
responsible human
get your life insurance right now okay
so
nancy pelosi again seems very very
confident no matter how long voting goes
biden will be elected
also she says trump should take his loss
like a man somebody needs to inform
nancy pelosi that i have been reliably
informed that some
men have periods i don't even know what
it means to take a loss like a man
anymore considering she cannot actually
define the word man
nonetheless here is nancy pelosi
the easiest thing for him to do is to
stand up like a man
and accept the results of an election of
the american people
for him to make these kinds of
statements shows his lack of patriotism
his undermining of our elections while
he allows foreign countries like his
friend putin
to undermine the integrity of our
election he himself
isn't doing it as well ah so trump is
undermining the integrity of the
election
by talking about about voter fraud
meanwhile democrats are not undermining
the integrity of the election by
constantly suggesting that millions of
people are about to be disenfranchised
so let's talk about that for a second so
a wide variety of states have taken
variant measures with regard to
covid19 and when the balloting deadline
will be
now it seems to me that it was idiotic
in the extreme in the first place
to make all of these bizarre sort of
legal
arrangements with regard to covet 19
considering that we've known for months
that you're not getting covered from a
polling place
they had massive polling in wisconsin
months ago like in the middle of the
pandemic
and there was not a major outbreak we've
had significant in-person voting across
the country in a variety of elections
since march and guess what no major
coveted outbreaks because standing in
line
outdoors six feet apart is not going to
give you covet we've known this for a
very very long time
nonetheless there was a major push by
democrats for mail-in voting
because their suggestion was and they
thought that they were going to be able
to consolidate that mail-in vote very
early
trump was campaigning against the
mail-in vote then trump realized he was
telling his own people not to vote in
not to mail in their votes so he
switched then the democrats were like oh
wait we told all our people not to go
out on election day that's bad so now
they need to go out on election day
here's the bottom line we have
procedures in this country for when
election day is we have procedures that
are followed and that are put in place
by the legislature for when you are
allowed to count ballots
usually the way this works under a
republican system of government is that
the legislature makes a law
and that law is the governing law and
judges don't get to willy-nilly rewrite
the law
and if they do that can be appealed to
the federal level because that is
violation of the republican form of
government
it is a violation of the federal laws
governing voting which are supposed to
really delegate not to state courts but
to state legislatures
and so this has been the the consistent
bizarre messaging surrounding voter
suppression
across the country the question is not
what the standard is there's always a
standard right
we could stop we could stop counting the
votes the day after the election we
could stop counting the votes 10 days
after the election we could stop
counting the votes
at midnight on election night right we
could do we could do any of those things
as long as the rules are set by the
proper body the question is not what the
rule
is the question is who sets the rule
so i saw chris hayes yesterday and he
was like imagine imagine if people just
said that we were going to stop
looking at your tax returns on april
15th imagine if we just shifted it and
we said that
if any any income tax return that was up
that was sent in after
april 15th we won't look at okay i can
imagine that and you know what happened
everybody would just mail it in two days
earlier
because it turns out that whatever the
deadline is is what the deadline is
institutionally and legally speaking the
question is
who gets to make the rules so the left
has been going nuts over this because
their suggestion is
no matter who makes the rule
right the it's it's the content of the
rule that matters not the process by
which the rule is made
so if a legislature correctly and and
legally makes a decision to cut off the
counting of the vote at midnight on
election night
and then a judge stands in without any
legal precedent and simply extends that
for seven days
the left is like excellent excellent and
it makes no difference to them
who actually creates the rule right and
then if you step in you say hold on the
legislature that's the legislature's job
you can't have members of the executive
agencies rewriting the law or you can't
have members of the judiciary rewriting
law then they call it voter suppression
that's not voter suppression guys
so take a perfect example the left
yesterday was fighting mad
freaking out freaking out over what's
going on in minnesota because on
thursday the eighth circuit court of
appeals
gave the gop a victory in minnesota
that's only a victory for the gop
because the gop had appealed the legal
process this hank berrien and daily wire
writing
ruling that minnesota absentee ballots
must be physically received by 8 pm on
election day in order to be counted
cbs minnesota reported previously a
ballot that was postmarked november 3rd
would still be counted so long as it
arrived within a week
the minnesota republican party said we
applaud the 8th circuit court of appeals
for upholding the integrity of the
election
and affirming election day as november
3rd so what was the court's actual
finding were they trying to suppress the
vote no
minnesota law dictates that election
officials only count ballots received by
election day
that is what it says in minnesota law
the minnesota alliance for retired
americans education fund and some of its
members sued
minnesota secretary of state steve
steinman in minnesota state court
alleging the statutory deadline was
unconstitutional
the secretary and the alliance then
entered into a consent decree purporting
to change the rules
by essentially making the statutory
mandated absentee ballot receipt
deadline
inoperative so in other words a bunch of
liberals went to another liberal the
secretary of state of minnesota and said
okay let's sign into
consensus created just rewrite the law
that's illegal you can't do that
you can't just have an outside group go
to the secretary of state and say you
know what here's the legislature's law
already signed into law by the governor
we're going to rewrite this on the side
you and me
you can't do this this is what the 8th
circuit court of appeals ruled
they said that the extension of the
deadline likely violates article 2
section 1 of the constitution
because the secretary extended the
deadline for a seat of the ballots
without legislative authorization
we therefore reverse the district
court's denial of a preliminary
injunction
and remands the district court to enter
an injunction requiring the secretary
and those under his direction to
identify
segregate and otherwise maintain and
preserve all absentee ballots received
after the deadlines
set forth in minneapolis state code
so they say that this has really screwed
up the process they say voter confusion
was inevitable
once the secretary issued guidance to
voters that was directly in
contradiction to minnesota
election law an orderly process was
hopelessly compromised when he usurped
the authority of the legislators
legislature under the elector's clause
of the constitution
during the entire tendency of this
litigation minnesota voters have been
left with two sets of contradicting
instructions
one from the secretary another that has
long been and remains codified in the
election laws of minnesota
in the end it is always in the public
interest to protect constitutional
rights in other words
the legislature gets to make the
decision naturally this has been
characterized by democrats as voter
suppression it is not
voter suppression okay just because i've
seen democrats claiming
there's a long line in a polling station
that's voter suppression no voter
suppression is when bull conor drives up
with a hose and starts hosing off all
the black people to prevent them from
voting that's voter suppression
standing in line is called being at a
grocery store at disneyland or voting
okay being in line is not voter
suppression voter suppression is when
you literally don't get to vote
it is also not voter suppression when
the legislature passes a law
saying you have to vote and it has to be
counted by the state
and then somebody tries to unilaterally
rewrite the law and then a court steps
in and says you can't unilaterally
rewrite the law that is also not voter
suppression
nonetheless you see democrats claiming
falsely that voter suppression is gonna
is going to be the uh the result of all
of this
so now nancy pelosi has shifted her
stance before it was everybody should
mail and vote
now democrats are deeply afraid that
trump is going to outweigh them on
election day right that's why she keeps
saying
trump may win on election day but keep
voting the can't keep counting the votes
long enough
biden will win here's pelosi saying i
hope people won't depend on their mail
and vote
this weekend shall be very interesting
to see how many more people will vote
in advance i hope that people will not
depend on the mail because they have
done all they can to dismantle
the postal system but i salute our
postal workers our letter carriers and
those
who are making the best of the situation
but even uh the postal service is saying
it's too late now to mail okay so let me
just point out again this is another
democratic myth the mail has not been
undermined it is fully funded through
next year
the post office delivers something like
300 million pieces of mail a day
okay they can obviously handle the
voting they they have been handling the
voting
all they requested way back early this
year is that you not make the voting
deadline
so late and close to the election that
it gives them no ability to actually
deliver the mail
properly so when people talk about ramp
up to violence in the election
when people talk about the possibility
of people not accepting the results of
the election
recognize the left is doing this
mainstream and the entire social media
infrastructure is echoing this voter
suppression is happening you're not
going to get your vote counted
how do you think things are going to go
if trump wins i mean seriously because
trump could still win
without bucking the polls trump could
win we'll get to that in just one second
first
i got to tell you about this incredible
new service okay this is really a
fantastic service
so i take lots of photos of my kids
right but then they just sit there on my
phone and then eventually i get around
to
uploading them to a computer and maybe i
print them out maybe i don't and then
they
they sort of go by the wayside right i
just forget about them well what if
there was a service where you could send
that photo in to a service and the
service would send you back
a beautifully printed photo that that
photo
to you on acrylic or wood on a beautiful
piece of product
okay some of the most beautiful photos
in my house they come from myphoto.com
it's a game changer
it is crazy easy and crazy fast to take
any photo and you can make it
immediately into a metal
glass wood creation it's fantastic it
takes two minutes to do it you get it in
five days
it comes in a stunning gift box so if
you're shopping for the holidays for
friends and family
this is like the best gift ever it's
fantastic these guys have literally made
millions of customers memories come to
life forever you have to try it now go
to myphoto.com
you can easily see your photo on all
their products and then simply purchase
use the promo code ben25 today for 25
off again use the promo code ben25 today
for 25
off by going to myphoto.com again that's
myphoto.com
use the code ben25 get 25 off you'll see
how easy and fun it is
it's fantastic it makes all your photos
look great i've got a bunch of them all
around the house right now and it's
super easy again because all i'm doing
is just like sending the photo into the
surface and i get back
this incredible product by the way i
know the founders of the company
honorable wonderful people
like people i really trust personally on
a personal level i trust the founders of
this company go check out myphoto.com
right now use the promo code ben25 today
for 25 percent off send in your photos
and get back
this wood metal acrylic glass creation
it's fantastic fantastic stuff
myphoto.com
use code bend25 get 25 percent off right
now
okay so it is possible that trump wins
i know democrats don't want to accept
this it is possible that trump wins and
it's possible that he wins without there
being voter suppression or voter fraud
obviously but democrats don't want to
accept any of this okay michael moore
who predicted that trump was going to
win last time he says he thinks trump is
going to win this time now listen you
got to always take this with a grain of
salt
i don't do election predictions anymore
one of the reasons is because all of the
incentive structures are skewed for
election predictions
if you're the one person who bucks the
data and says trump is going to win and
then trump wins
then everybody declares that you are a
prophet if you are the person who
follows the data and says that trump is
going to lose
you don't get any credit right because
you followed the data if you are the
person who says the trump is going to
win and then he loses everybody just
forgets about it immediately
that's the way this works but michael
moore who did call it last time
he says he thinks that trump is going to
win again
i wake up every morning with the
assumption that trump believes
he's going to win and that's good enough
for me
if he thinks he's going to win then i
think he's going to win
and i'm going to act every minute of
today
and the rest of the day until i fall
asleep after midnight
i am going to be working to make sure he
doesn't win because
he thinks he's going to win and i know
he's an evil genius and he's smarter
than all of us
okay michael moore man okay so there is
one area where trump
could pull kind of a stunner what the
polls are showing is something that
people don't really want to recognize
which is the trump is drawing an outside
share of both the hispanic vote and the
black vote particularly among black
males among black females
black females hate the guy i mean just
by polling data but among black males
there's a heavier share of the black
male vote going to trump than any other
republican candidate of my lifetime
which people on the left find absolutely
astounding but i'm not sure why it's
astounding considering that he has
pursued criminal justice reform for
example
considering that he has pursued these
opportunity zones
considering that he has been featured in
rap songs going back to the 90s
as sort of the prototypical rich guy
right so he's sort of been
in some ways heroized by rap for for
several decades
lil weezy came out yesterday lil wayne
wheezy i have no experience with this as
you know
despite the fact i am myself a platinum
award-winning rapper
i really have no experience with
anything around this lil wayne who i
guess is also known as wheezy
he tweeted out just had a great meeting
with president trump besides what he's
done so far with criminal reform
the platinum plan is going to give the
community real ownership he listened to
what we had to say today
and assured he will and can get it done
and of course lil wayne then received an
extraordinary amount of blowback because
you are not allowed to say that donald
trump is a decent man you can't say that
not allowed to say that donald trump
might not be a racist
even taking a picture with donald trump
is underscoring the fact he might not be
a racist and that you are not
allowed to say okay so the the democrats
have not accepted the possibility that
trump possibly
could win and so we all know that the
the plausible outcome right at trump
wins
if trump wins everybody assumes the
cities are going to burn right this is
the corollary to the blackmail the demo
the moral blackmail democrats have been
using here you're a bad person if you
vote for trump therefore if trump wins
the bad people won
therefore if trump wins and the bad
people won rebellion is necessary right
the nature of this country has been
shifted dramatically
the fascists have won it's time to loot
and break things you know who knows that
this is the reality
that this is a real possibility every
business in america
seriously all of them dc luxury shops
are already boarding up in anticipation
of the election
which just goes to show you the rioters
and looters you think they're trump
supporters
for all the talk about the fascist brown
shirts running around the land creating
violence
it seems like a lot of people who are
going to vote for joe biden who if they
vote at all
who are going to go break into stores
should donald trump win
walmart is now removing guns and ammo
from store displays ahead of the
election
because they are worried about civil
unrest the news was first reported by
the wall street journal
which said the retailer was looking to
head off any potential theft of firearms
if stores are broken into
amid any civil unrest caused by the
upcoming presidential election on
tuesday by the way
my theory there will be civil unrest
either way if biden wins people are
going to use it as an opportunity
to go ahead and break things and steal
things but if trump wins the world will
burn
if trump wins people will go out in the
streets it will get extremely violent
extremely quickly and we all know this
right this is not some sort of big
secret
walmart said we have seen some isolated
civil unrest and as we've done on
several locations over the last few
years
we've moved our firearms and ammo off
the sales floor as a precaution for the
safety of our associates and customers
the
items do remain available for purchase
by customers
a new usa today self-a university poll
found americans are increasingly worried
about what will happen as this year's
tumultuous election comes to a
conclusion
next week including whether the voting
will be peaceful and the outcome broadly
accepted
only one in four say they are very
confident the nation will have a
peaceful transfer of power if democratic
challenger joe biden defeats
president donald trump but that of
course is the wrong question the real
question is if trump wins
will anybody on the left accept that and
i think the answer is going to be almost
universally no and of course they'll be
fully justified and not accepting it
because trump is a terrible fascist and
it's all voter suppression
it's amazing how the media have focused
entirely on trump's allegations of voter
fraud
prediction right now if joe biden wins
the election no widespread violence from
the right how do i know this
because regardless of what has happened
on the right there's been no widespread
violence from the right
okay it's just not a thing the tea party
was not violent black lives matter
protests routinely break out in violence
the tea party was not violent occupy
wall street routinely
broke out into acts of lawlessness it is
the left that is constantly engaged in
extra-legal activity
when they don't get what they want and
meanwhile
i think it is worthwhile examining
what's going on over at the biden
campaign
biden's closing pitch again is the same
as it ever was which is donald trump as
a mean bad very bad orange man
but every so often we are reminded of
just how bad joe biden is going to be
we'll get to that in just one second
first let's talk about a great
meaningful gift
okay so above our couch in our new house
is a beautiful portrait
of me and my wife and two of our three
children and we
fully intend on now going out and doing
a photo shoot
with our new baby and then we're gonna
take one of those photos we're going to
send it into paint your life and get a
brand new portrait it's a professional
hand-painted portrait created from any
photo at a truly affordable price
send any picture yourself your family
family a special place
cherish pet combine photos in one
painting with paint your life's
compilation portraits you can even bring
together family members who have never
even met or you can create a portrait of
the whole family without the need for
everyone to be there for a family photo
you choose from a team of world-class
artists and you work with them until
every detail is perfect
you can order a custom-made hand-painted
portrait in less than five minutes it's
a quick and easy process get a hand
painted portrait in about three weeks
it's meaningful it's personal and it can
be cherished forever at painterlife.com
there is no risk if you don't love that
final painting your money is refunded
and they work with you like the whole
way like we actually corrected our
painting a couple of times before we
were satisfied with it and then they
sent it to us
right now as a limited time offer get
twenty percent off your painting that is
correct
twenty percent off and free shipping to
get this special offer
text the word ben to sixty four thousand
that's ben to sixty four thousand again
text ben to sixty 64 000 paint your life
celebrate the moments that matter most
okay in just one second we'll get to the
biden campaign
reminder if joe biden becomes president
it ain't going to be great bob
it's not going to be good we'll get to
that in a second first it is that
glorious time of the week when i give a
shout out to a daily wire member today
it is charlotte catherine on instagram
who understands proper
halloween messaging in this picture two
skeletons stand on the front porch
prepared to greet trick-or-treaters
one is wearing a voter dye t-shirt while
the other holds the world's greatest
beverage vessel in one hand and a sign
saying
still waiting for socialism to work
which is excellent
the caption reads in a neighborhood full
of lawn sign virtue signaling
it helps remind people that facts don't
care about your feelings my peacefully
protesting skeletons stay hydrated with
the most glorious drinking vessel
a leftist years tumbler their cup
literally runeth over hashtag socialism
sucks
hashtag halloween decor well done best
house on the block
bar none thanks for the pick and thanks
for being a daily wire member by the way
if you want to be featured become a
daily wire member
this could be you next week also you may
have noticed the country is falling
apart
and there's a massive conflict of
visions as i've been talking about for
literally years at this point what we
are watching is the breakdown of america
in real time into two groups
one that believes that america's
fundamental rights ought to be preserved
and one that believes america's
fundamental rights are indeed
the actual obstacle to prosperity and
decency and equality
okay that is the great battle of our
time if you want to educate your kids if
you want to educate the college students
you know if you want to educate your
friends
on what is at stake why american
philosophy is good why american history
is good pick up a copy of my book how to
destroy america in three easy steps
it is a vital read i mean really i wrote
because i thought it was important i
think it's even more important now
i think it'll be even more important to
post the election because there needs to
be
a reacquaintance with the founding
principles of the country and we need to
understand why people are attacking
those founding principles how to destroy
america in three easy steps go pick it
up
at amazon.com or anywhere else that
books are sold also
this weekend we have another great
episode of the sunday special this time
with author columnist documentarian
shelby steele you've heard me reference
his work before it is fantastic
in our conversation shelby details his
struggles with amazon and the journey he
has gone through
to get his important documentary made
it's a documentary all about black lives
matter and
michael brown and the lies about michael
brown steele and i discuss
the reason president trump and his
supporters are so often labeled as
racist
and the huge issue underlying so much of
american politics white guilt
so head on over watch early at
dailywire.com listen to sunday on apple
podcast
spotify or wherever else you get your
podcast here's a bit of a taste
freedom is not that interesting in black
america what's interesting is this
enormous power
that befell us in the 60s when america
owned up to
to its past
alrighty head on over to dailywire.com
or listen this sunday on apple podcast
spotify or wherever else
you get your podcast also the
presidential election
it's almost here we have an amazing day
of programming scheduled for you our
live stream starts november
3rd tuesday 3 p.m eastern 12 p.m pacific
it features special guests
live interviews an elephant and more
leading up to our evening show where
we'll be covering the results with you
in real time even better join daily wear
right now get 25
off with kodi election so you can watch
all of our election coverage live on our
apple tv or roku app
members get our articles ad free access
to all of our live broadcasts and show
library the full three hours of the ben
shapiro show and an exclusive
reader's past content available only to
daily wire members also
i can't wait to show you all the new
stuff we're going to unleash in the new
year like tons and tons of new material
behind the paywall
in the new year if you're considering an
all-access membership you get to join us
on all access live every night for
online live stream discussions with our
hosts
and an amazing online community you also
get not one but two
leftist tiers tumblers with your
membership as well as early sometimes
exclusive access to new daily wire
products and as i say we're going to be
rolling out a bunch of brand new awesome
stuff
in the new year so watch the election
with us at dailywire.com get 25
off your daily wire membership with code
election when you sign up today you are
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
okay so just a quick reminder this
election is not just about the supposed
evils of donald trump
joe biden will be president if joe biden
is elected i know people forget about
that
because we have been told that the
signal sign of your own evil is voting
for president trump and so you can
alleviate your evil simply you can
exercise that evil by just voting for
joe biden there's only one problem joe
biden then becomes president so
yesterday joe biden was speaking and he
was talking about being a standard
bearer for democracy
this just shows you the overt lies that
are told by joe biden he said
he was campaigning in florida before he
was hit with a rainstorm he immediately
ran away from the rainstorm which
you know not a great shock and william
henry harrison died 40 days into his
term because he stayed out in a
rainstorm
although i will say that the rain in
florida is quite warm anyway here was
joe biden
suggesting that donald trump is a
terrorist terrible standard bearer for
democracy
i will explain how idiotic this
statement is in just one moment
president trump can't advance democracy
and human rights for the cuban people
or the venezuelan people for that matter
when he has embraced so many autocrats
around the world
sort of vladimir putin and kim jong-un
of north korea
trump is the worst possible standard
bearer for democracy
in places like cuba venezuela
north korea okay i have to just say that
last line there is one of the stupidest
things i've ever heard your biden say
and that man says stupid things every
single day
every single day i mean first of all he
is obviously losing his crips
crispness just in his articulation there
but beyond that okay for him to say
that trump is a terrible standard bearer
for democracy in cuba and venezuela
dude dude dude dude
let me just okay the reason he's
mentioning cuba and venezuela in florida
is obviously there are tons of
cuban expatriates and their children
there are a lot of new expatriates to
flora who are venezuelan and who are
voting republican because they don't
wish america to look like nicolas maduro
and hugo chavez in venezuela just a
quick note
joe biden's plan okay this is coming out
today joe biden's plan is to dump over
juan juano
in venezuela who is the head of the
assembly who was
who was supposed to be the sort of
interim president
once maduro who's a dictator was deposed
he's planning to dump over
huaydo just abandon him completely and
go back to negotiating with nicolas
maduro who's a brutal dictator
right who's been suppressing the people
of venezuela i mean hugo chavez and
maduro reduced
the most oil-rich country in south
america into a trash heap
people literally eating dogs to survive
and it's been going on for years on end
okay the obama administration wants to
deal with maduro
they did nothing to stop maduro they did
nothing to stop hugo chavez
i mean it is it is fully crazy how
accommodating they were to the
venezuelan regime
and speaking of cuba i mean it was
barack obama who said he wanted to
reopen cuba and then went and hung out
with raul castro and there's the famous
photo of our old castro holding up
barack obama's arm and obama's got the
limp wrist in the whole deal
i mean seriously that's the actual photo
as i'm making fun of obama that's the
actual photo
there's a picture of barack obama in
cuba standing in front
of a giant mural of shay guevara barack
obama was at baseball games with raul
castro
he said don't tell me that the great
standard bearer for democracy is going
to be joe biden in cuba and venezuela
i mean it's just like the number of lies
that joe biden thinks he can tell just
because donald trump is orange man who's
bad and orange
is truly crazy it's truly crazy and of
course joe biden still doesn't have to
answer any questions about his son
so it's not just that joe biden like
listen there's still
lack of substantiation on joe biden
being
directly involved in business with his
son or benefiting directly from business
with his son
there is no controversy at all that joe
biden knows full well that his son
hunter was jet-setting all over the
globe doing corrupt deals on the basis
of his name he was allowing members of
his family to do this for literally
decades for literally decades
now there's a report from
james rosen that the justice department
has confirmed that in 2019 the fbi
actually opened up a criminal
investigation into hunter biden and his
associates
focused on allegations of money
laundering and that that investigation
remains open
and active today rosen is a reporter
with the sinclair broadcast
group of course this follows hard on
tony bobolinsky suggesting that he was
questioned by six fbi agents pablinsky
is hunter biden's former business
partner with council president for five
hours on october 23rd
listing him as a material witness in an
ongoing investigation focused on hunter
biden
and his associates an fbi spokesman told
the washington examiner we have no
comment
in keeping with our standard practice of
neither confirming nor denying the
existence of an investigation
materials of course tied to hunter biden
come from a laptop that he apparently
left
with a computer repair store in delaware
and then abandoned and then it ended up
in the hands of rudy giuliani and such
now biden's people keep
refusing to answer the question and
again it is perfectly plausible for joe
biden to say i've never made money off
of any of this
but he has said hunter by never did
anything wrong and that there are no
serious accusations hunter biden has
ever done anything wrong
well that's not true i mean that
honestly that's not true
there have been lots of accusations that
hunter biden has done wrong stuff hunter
by himself acknowledges that he benefits
from daddy's name in order to pick up
bags of cash in foreign countries where
he has no connections
naturally biden spoke people refused to
answer any questions at all
because we saw big tech react the way
they did on the new york post story
that the allegations in it are are off
the table they are false as far as
you're concerned
look we're not going to waste any
seconds on this smear campaign so to
clarify we there were more accusations
made this week
uh on that most watched fox news
interview a couple nights ago from
tucker carlson did those meetings happen
as they have been alleged when joe biden
was a private citizen
we're not going to waste any time on
this smear campaign of course
they don't have to waste any time on
this quote unquote smear campaign
because the media is
covering up for them no matter what they
do here's msnbc's stephanie rule saying
the entire hunter biden story has been
debunked
which is weird because it has not in
fact been debunked do you think we need
to know
who president trump personally owes over
400 million dollars to in the next four
years
well the touche point here is uh would
be simply do you think we ought to know
more about hunter biden's laptop and
that so let's not go there
absolutely we should note hunter biden
isn't running for president that
argument has been debunked
okay no the argument has not been
debunked the question is what joe biden
knew when he knew it and how involved he
was
and tony babilinski says that hunter and
joe were deeply enmeshed and involved
that has yet to be rebutted don't worry
though the media will just cover up for
it
so now they're trying to misdirect
there's an entire article from nbc news
today called how a fake persona laid the
groundwork for a hunter-biden conspiracy
deluge
one month before a purported leak of
files from hunter biden's laptop a fake
intelligence document about him went
viral on the right-wing internet
asserting an elaborate conspiracy theory
involving vice president joe biden's son
and business in china the document a
64-page composition that was later
disseminated by close associates of
president trump
appears to be the work of a fake
intelligence firm called typhoon
investigations okay there's only one
problem with this as kimberly strassel
points out
none of this has to do with hundreds
laptop okay that fake dossier that was
passed out
has nothing to do with any of the
stories we've ever talked about on the
show not one story that we've ever
talked about on the show
so now the media are putting focus on an
actual fake story so they don't have to
cover the very real story of hunter
biden's laptop because guess what
it has now been confirmed that according
to the new york post forensic analysis
says that all of the hunter biden emails
are 100 percent authentic
and so we're not going to focus on that
instead we are going to focus on
non-authentic emails so as to misdirect
from serious questions about all of this
well glenn greenwald who uh i am no fan
of glenn greenwald and glenn greenwald i
know is no fan of mine
and glenn greenwald has routinely taken
i think anti-american positions
he was doing propaganda on behalf of
wikileaks
he has been an enemy of the state of
israel for a very long time
and very much in favor of israel
compromising his own security
glenn greenwald i disagree an awful lot
but glenn greenwald has at least been
consistent enough
to call out the hunter biden story and
to call out false claims about
russian collusion well now he has
resigned from the intercept which is an
organization he founded on thursday
afternoon signaling an abrupt and
acrimonious end to his time at the
publication
he co-founded in 2014 with jeremy
scahill and laura poitras
greenwald who shared the 2014 pulitzer
prize for public service for his
reporting on the nsa
in domestic that was uncovered by edward
snowden said his departure was related
to a piece he planned to write about the
former vice president
joe biden in a lengthy note published on
substance greenwald said the publication
refused to publish the piece
in violation of my contractual right of
editorial freedom unless he removed all
sections critical
of democratic presidential candidate joe
biden the candidate vehemently supported
by all new york-based intercept editors
involved in this effort at suppression
the intercept instead
said no no he's just whining that he was
asked to support his claims and innuendo
about corrupt actions by joe biden
with evidence and they said it's
preposterous that glenn greenwald
is accusing them of any sort of bias at
all so
there's a schrodinger watching the left
attack itself this way but
when glenn greenwald quits the
organization that he founded saying that
they are trying to suppress stories on
behalf of joe biden
you know that is not a nothing that is
not nothing okay meanwhile
the new push by the media because the
economy is in a state of recovery
and because it is absolutely clear at
this point by all available evidence
that you cannot control the pandemic you
can't
okay there's no way to do it the only
way to quote unquote control the
pandemic is with full-scale lockdowns
that destroy the economy and only delay
the pandemic they do not destroy the
pandemic
okay that is the reality of the
situation the pandemic that has struck
america is now striking europe
europe is having rates it has never seen
before in countries that were locked
down right germany was a success story
now germany is experiencing thousands
and thousands and thousands of cases
france was until very recently
experiencing a downturn in cases and now
they've seen a massive uptick
in the number of cases italy is
experiencing a massive uptick in cases
after it was widely assumed that they'd
gotten this thing under control
with mass mandates for example right so
this thing is going to hit everywhere
and it's going to be bad and it's going
to kill a lot of people
and honestly the only thing that you can
do is when you're in close quarters you
socially distance as much as you can
and you wear a mask in close quarters
but mask mandates have actually done
virtually nothing
right germany as of october 29th had
almost 19 000 cases
19 000 cases in a day in germany okay
that that is a massive
number of cases in germany which was one
of the big success stories
so here's the reality about covert you
can't stop it you can only hope to quote
unquote contain it
okay and all you can really do is try to
shield the most vulnerable by telling
them to stay home
and then if a bunch of 20 year olds get
it a bunch of 20 year olds get it
i've been a long time a proponent of the
idea that if you are 20 years old and
you're at university and you get this
thing that is not the end of the world
you should just isolate from your
elderly relatives
i've been long time a proponent of the
the basic idea proposed by hebrew
university
scientists suggesting what they call
control the avalanche the idea being
that if you are ever to reach hurt
immunity because a vaccine may only be
50 to 60
effective i know bad news right it is
bad news
but that is a reality and you can either
deal with reality or not deal with
reality a vaccine may only be 50 to 60
effective there's no guarantee 100 of
people are going to take it in the first
place
therapeutics are getting better there's
no guarantee that therapeutics are going
to save anybody's life
okay the hospitalization versus death
rate hospitalization rate is up
death rate is down these are all
baseline facts
with that said if you ever reach if you
ever hope to reach some level of herd
immunity
that's going to have to happen by
protecting and shielding the vulnerable
and the elderly
and by basically allowing the virus to
move as it will through a 20 year old
population right you start with the
least vulnerable populations and if they
get it they get it
and that's not the end of the world
pretending that a 20-year-old getting
coveted and recovering from it is the
end of the world
is ridiculous anti-scientific nonsense
okay but naturally because the economy
is recovering and because
the baseline awareness that you can't
contain the virus is setting in
this is driving the media up a wall
because their entire narrative is that
donald trump blew this this is all
donald trump's fault
so in donald trump's narrative which is
basically that we're going to have to
live our lives and learn to live with
the virus
becomes the mainstream narrative then
the talking point about covet goes away
but democrats and members of the media
but i repeat myself continue
to push talking points about kova that
are just outdated so here's shep smith
now over at cnbc asking anthony fauci
why we cannot impose a
day lockdown the way they did in new
zealand okay new zealand has had a 111
day lockdown they locked down the entire
country
when there were four cases in the
country okay and the answer is because
we have an economy supporting 330
million people plus the rest of the
globe
that is the reason the reason is because
you should not
lock hundreds of millions of healthy
people in their homes
because that is a violation of basic
civil liberties you certainly should not
do so when we are not talking about
airborne ebola when you are talking
about a virus that largely targets
people who are identifiable namely the
elderly and the infirm
and when you're talking about a virus
with death rates for people below the
age of 20 that are lower than that of
the flu
here's chef smith though begging anthony
fought you why can't we just lock down
the entire country you know indefinitely
you were talking about what an
extraordinary thing has happened in
melbourne
they had a 111 day lockdown started with
20 000 cases a day and as you pointed
out two days ago they had
zero cases why can't we do that
when you talk about lockdowns that
certainly they were extremely successful
there is very little appetite for
lockdown in this country
there's going to be a major pushback
both from above
and at the local level okay well yes
it's not just that there's pushback is
that there ought to be pushback
sacrificing every freedom and liberty
that you have on the basis of a virus
that again
is deadlier than the flu but it's not
nearly as deadly as many of the other
diseases that we have talked about as
being you know kind of contagion-style
diseases
it is it is foolishness i mean even the
who at this point says that lockdowns
are bad
nonetheless the narrative must never be
released so dr vin gupta over at msnbc
he says that it's time to shut down
schools and restaurants
okay there's a case to be made with
regard to closed air restaurants
there's no case you made with regard to
schools even europe has the schools open
still
do i think that indoor dining craig do i
think that's
that in-person schooling are likely
going to we're going to have to
reconsider
those particular parts of society right
now in the midst of an out of control
pandemic
yes i do because right now the only way
you can safely open up schools
craig is on-site testing and unless
you're an affluent school district you
don't have access
to it right now indoor dining we know
it's needless
and we know that that's been a source of
of of spread of this virus so i do
think that certain parts okay on the
restaurant he's not totally wrong
on the schools he's utterly and
absolutely wrong and my kids have been
in school there's been no outbreak
okay the reason there's been no outbreak
is because you're asked to fill in a
wellness report every day
if any kid shows the symptom they're
immediately sent home and then they're
quarantined until they
can be determined whether they are
healthy plus kids are not passing this
in the same numbers as adults
particularly kids under the age of 10.
okay this is all anti-scientific okay
that's anti-scientific stuff
the it is all based on a myth the myth
is that
we know the solution to kovid and the
solution to covet is all the stuff trump
doesn't want to do so trump doesn't want
to do lockdowns
that means that the solution to covet is
lockdown trump doesn't like masks
particularly much that means that the
solution to covet
is masking so joe biden is now pushing
national mass mandates
according to the new york times as the
nation heads it's what public health
experts are calling
a dark winter of coronavirus illness and
death public health experts are
coalescing around joe biden's call for a
national mass mandate
even as they concede such an effort
would require much more than the stroke
of a presidential pen
over the past week a string of prominent
public health experts notably fauci
dr scott gottlieb former commissioner of
the fda under trump have said it is time
to seriously consider a national mandate
to curb the spread
of the virus overseas this week
president vladimir putin of russia
became the latest foreign leader to
impose a national mandate for citizens
to wear masks
biden has conceded a presidential order
for americans to wear masks will almost
certainly face and most likely fall to a
legal challenge
biden has already said that as president
he would mandate masks on all federal
property
an executive order that could
theoretically have wide reach also he
could require masks on public
transportation under federal transit law
and he could prod governors who are
resisting mass mandates to at least
require masks
in public buildings in their states okay
so let's talk
talk about mass mandates for a second
first of all when caseload gets heavy
people wear masks
this is what the data show it does not
matter whether it is a mandate or
whether there is no mandate
when there is a big uptick in florida
florida is not a mass mandate state
guess what people started wearing masks
when there was no uptick in florida
people were not wearing masks
when there's heavy cases in texas people
will start wearing masks people take
action to protect
themselves this is a thing that they do
national mask mandates threatening to
throw people in jail or find them for
not wearing a mask properly first of all
the vast majority of people who are
wearing masks are not doing so in
medically approved fashion
it's better than nothing in some cases
but in a lot of cases i mean how many
times do you see somebody walking around
the mask under their nose virtue
signaling
how many times do you see people wearing
neck gaiters those are pretty
controversial scientifically as to
whether those are helpful
or whether they are in fact not helpful
in fact
one thing that we know about masked
mandates is that there are no guarantee
of preventing an uptick
you know weiss has gone through the data
over on twitter he's a data guy
and here are just some graphs of how
mass mandates have worked out in
particular countries
okay so if you look at european coven 19
cases per million
masks required versus no masks required
what you see is sweden norway and
denmark
are coming in well below right now
germany ireland portugal italy austria
uk spain france czech republic and
belgium all of which have
mass mandates okay so it is not really
about mass mandates being the great
solution
and you can do this by country right you
know and weiss goes through this
so take a look for example at austria so
austria
mandated masks after they had already
hit the downslope of their original wave
that mass mandate never waned they
didn't get rid of the masked mandate
now austria is experiencing 250 cases
per million
okay they put in a mass mandate when
they are experiencing about 50 cases per
million
okay or take a look at germany in
mandated masks about halfway down their
original recovery according to
union-wise
okay when they were about 25 cases per
million now
they're experiencing close to 120 cases
per million that mass mandate never
waned
how about france so france waited longer
to mandate the masks
they have about 1 000 percent the daily
cases when they mandated masks
despite having one of the highest mass
compliance levels in the world
spain put in a mask mandate hey spain
put in a mass mandate
around may 17th may 20th
okay they are now 15 100 up on their
case level
the british held out on masks for a long
time then they mandated masks and guess
what
did not stop the wave if this does not
mean that masks are useless
masks are useful in certain scenarios
but the idea that a mask mandate is
going to solve this thing is absolute
silliness
people are going to wear masks when they
feel like they're in danger they're not
going to wear masks when they don't feel
like they are in danger
but again this is all about promulgating
a narrative in the united states that
the solution is at hand
and that all that is required is for joe
biden to implement that solution the
data are not there
this is why when i hear people on the
left say follow the science follow the
science
i'm sorry but the democratic party is
not following the science they're not
this is the same democratic party
downplaying the vaccine
i mean andrew cuomo the worst governor
in america andrew cuomo who's out
pushing a book about what a great job he
did with covid
in a state that had the second worst
death permillion rate in america
he now he's now saying the federal
government hasn't started to focus on a
coveted vaccine like this he's spouting
absolute bull crap but he's captain
science here here is andrew cuomo
upheld by the dnc as a as a model of
what you should do about covet
this is basically let's call it half
time in the game right
we went through the first phase we had a
brief respite before the fall
and now we're going to have the fall and
the winter and
then vaccination which is a whole
[Music]
long difficult a process
that the federal government hasn't even
started to focus on it's not about
finding the vaccine you then have to
administer
330 million doses right okay um actually
the federal government has been working
on that for quite a long time you idiot
by the way he also lies about his own
record he then says
conspiracy theory if you're worried
about nursing homes in new york despite
the fact that there was an actual policy
to ship people
with covid back into nursing homes and
that he would then refused
to reveal the actual stats on how many
people had died in nursing homes and
falsified the stats by claiming that
people who were diagnosed with coveted
nursing homes and then died at the
hospital were not actually in nursing
homes here is liar and fabulous to
andrew cuomo
if you look at how many people died in
new york
nursing homes new york is number 46
out of 50 states in the percentage of
deaths in nursing homes
the conspiracy they're trying to to
spread just it has no
factual basis but yes
people in nursing homes died and they're
playing politics with the issue
which i think is especially cruel okay
dude you put out a poster you sold a
poster about your own incredible
performance
after a horrifying performance and a
creation of a death curve that looked a
lot like the
don't have this death curve chart that
we were all shown at the beginning of
the pandemic
but don't worry this is the party of
science this is the party of science
okay meanwhile just a quick note the the
issues that plague the united states the
the
gap between people in the united states
who believe that the western
civilization is worthy of upholding
and that american philosophy is worthy
of upholding that gap continues
to exist nation not not just in the
united states it continues to exist
across the west i'd be remiss if i
didn't comment on a story
that happened in france over the course
of the last few days
there were two separate horrifying
attacks two separate horrifying attacks
in france
three people died in a knife attack in a
church in nice over the last couple of
days and what french president emmanuel
macron said was
was an islamist terror attack he said
france would not surrender its core
values after visiting the notre dame
basilica
in the southern city an extra 4 000
troops were being deployed to protect
churches
and schools in nice in nice one elderly
victim was virtually beheaded
another woman and a man also died a male
suspect was shot and detained
well presumably they should have tried
to tase him according to those who don't
like the police
anti-terror prosecutors have opened an
investigation into the attack france has
raised its national security alert
to its highest level according to the
french anti-terrorist prosecutor
jean-francois ricard he said the
attacker was seriously wounded by police
that he was a 21-year-old tunisian
national
who arrived in france earlier this month
he had a document issued by the italian
red cross
he had traveled by boat from tunisia to
the italian island of lampedusa
in september he was placing coronavirus
quarantine there before he was released
and told
to leave italy the suspect had been
cutting off people's heads
while shouting endlessly allahu akbar
two other attacks took place on thursday
one in france and one in saudi arabia
a man was shot dead in mount favette
near the southern french city of amignon
after testing after threatening police
with a handgun also a guard was
attacked outside the french consulate in
jeddah in saudi arabia a suspect was
arrested
the guard was taken to the hospital this
of course follows
closely on the recent murder of the
teacher samuel patti who was beheaded
close to his school outside paris
earlier this month after he showed a
cartoon
of the prophet muhammad in his classroom
police have not suggested a motive for
the attacking ease i think that the part
where he's screaming allahu akbar while
chopping off someone's head is a pretty
good indicator
it follows days of protests in some
muslim majority countries triggered
by president macron's defense of the
publication of cartoons that depicted
muhammad there have been calls in some
countries for a boycott of french goods
so two people died in the church a
six-year-old woman who was virtually
beheaded a 55 year old man whose throat
was cut
apparently the man was responsible for
the upkeep of the church and had a wife
and two kids another woman who was 44
fled to a nearby cafe after she was
stabbed several times she died later
so what we are watching in france is a
a small wave of terrorism that follows
hard upon controversy
over people showing a cartoon of
muhammad
the question is whether the west is
going to have
enough of a belief in its own value
system to stand up
to this sort of disgusting
islamic fascism okay not all muslims
believe this stuff there are many many
muslims
many muslims some of whom i've talked to
on this program who believe that you
have the right to show a picture
of muhammad that you have that you you
can do all of that and not have your
head chopped off
unfortunately there are in fact hundreds
of millions of people who believe that
if you show a picture of the prophet
muhammad
that at the very least you might want to
have you may deserve to have your head
chopped off and to pretend this is a
completely fringe phenomenon
is to ignore the fact that it is not in
fact a completely french phenomenon how
do we know
this because the prime minister of
malaysia the former prime minister of
malaysia
okay malaysia is a country with a
population
of right now 31.53 million people
malaysia it is one of the largest muslim
countries on planet earth
the former prime minister of malaysia
tweeted out
muslims have a right to be angry and to
kill millions of french people for the
massacres of the past
muhammad said killing is not act that a
muslim that as a muslim i would approve
but he also doesn't think insulting
other people should be included in
freedom of expression
he said you cannot go up to a man and
curse him simply because you believe in
freedom of speech
irrespective of the religion professed
angry people kill the french in the
course of their history have killed
millions of people many were muslims
since you have blamed all muslims and
the muslims religion for what was done
by one angry person the muslims have a
right to punish the french
any boycott cannot compensate the wrongs
committed by the french all these years
and that's when he said muslims have a
right to be angry and kill millions of
french people for the massacres
of the past twitter
twitter hesitated on this they didn't
ban the tweet immediately it's one thing
to ban the new york post
like right off the bat for publishing
emails from hunter biden it's another to
ban people
saying that muslims have the right to
kill millions of french people from a
former
prime minister of malaysia but it is
that
there's one line in there that is worthy
of note when he says you cannot go up to
a man and curse him simply because you
believe
in freedom of speech okay this is a view
of free speech that unfortunately has
been taken up
by many people on the political left
scotland right now
is about to put forth a law that
basically allows for the arrest of
people
for hate speech okay it is scary scary
stuff
there's a scottish bill that would
criminalize hate speech in private homes
may read mcardle reporting for national
review a controversial bill making its
way through scotland's parliament would
criminalize hate speech
even if the offending wars were uttered
in someone's private home members of the
scottish parliament questioned justice
secretary hunza yusof
for the first time on tuesday about the
hate crime and public order bill
which would establish a new crime quote
unquote stirring up hatred the
legislation criminalizes hate speech
related to age
disability religion sexual orientation
transgender identity and variations in
sex characteristics
including potentially hate speech spoken
in private residences
after criticisms from groups saying that
the bill threatens to stifle free speech
yusuf agreed to amend the legislation
when it reaches stage two of
consideration
in parliament the amendment will
stipulate offenders may only be
prosecuted if they had quote unquote
intent
to stir a hatred he said he said i'm
very actively considering both the
breadth and depth of freedom of
expression clauses
we have to be aware of some of the
concerns that may be expressed if we
were to have a generic freedom of
expression clause would that be specific
enough to give people the reassurances
that they desire
it is a full-scale destruction of basic
individual rights
it is being pursued in western countries
it has unfortunately become a talking
point
of many on the left in the united states
as well which is that the individual
rights that you hold are a danger to
others the right to free speech is a
danger because
you might commit blasphemy right you
might harm somebody's perception of
their own religion
good for emmanuel macron he said no you
do have the right to actually exhibit
pictures of the prophet muhammad if you
wish to do so in a western country
i just wonder if as we move forward in
time as we continue to apologize
for western civilization as we continue
to apologize for our rights
as we continue to suggest that the roots
of western civilization lie in racism
bigotry
homophobia and cruelty if we are willing
to stand up for individual rights with a
multicultural left intent
on the idea that rights
are themselves responsible for the
violation of the rights that all you
have to do is curb rights and you'll
reach utopia
it doesn't mean that everybody's in
favor of beheading people who
draw pictures of muhammad but it doesn't
mean there are an awful lot of people on
the left
who would like to see that sort of
activity drawing muhammad made illegal
so as not to set people off
so we can all live in a world free of
offense
alrighty we will be back here on monday
because we have at that point
one day until the election rest up over
the weekend try not to burn things down
we'll see you then i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
borin
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
production manager pavel wydowsky our
associate producers are nick sheehan and
rebecca doyle
the show is edited by adam sci event
audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by nico geneva the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production
copyright daily wire 20 20. you know the
matt wall show
it's not just another show about about
politics i think there are enough of
those
already out there we talk about culture
because culture drives
politics and it drives everything else
so my main focuses are
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about i
hope you'll
give it a listen